I want to express some concern because I
know that you injured your vocal cords
your throat yeah somehow be doing as
this right for doing voiceover work yeah
well not my vocal cords luckily because
that seems to be something that happens
to singers and voiceover artists but the
musculature around my vocal cords I
injured from excessive use and not
repairing myself correctly this is from
doing voice work right yeah there was a
period of about 18 months where I was
doing four different cartoons and a
video game and you just don't think
about the concentration of that work or
that you would injure yourself in the
process of it but that's exactly what
happened and instead of taking enough
rest I just kept working so it's like
running on a broken leg and then it just
doesn't set correctly right which I've
never done
you said the video game I was talking
about stage and you said the video game
was the hardest thing I was thinking
about it video games would be very hard
if you were a prominent voice because
well you just don't really think about
it but for every bit of dialogue that
leads a player through the game from
something as simple as hmm I should
investigate this box to like getting
shot by several different armaments you
you wind up doing I did 10 for our
records for this one game just because
you've got to think of every scenario
the player make take you through well
there was a bunch of DLC for the game
and so they kept changing what the style
of downloadable content yeah what the
this time we all knew what you were
talking about
I'll do the DLC that's the that's the
area between North and South Korea we
all know you were talking to Andy you've
done this too you've done voiceover work
does it is it get to the point where
it's like I can't do this anymore
sometimes Anna well I did the character
Mort from the Madagascar movies right
that talks like this you know it's a
very it's a very high voice by the way
this house so how Andy orders fast yeah
yeah
[Laughter]
yeah yeah but after yeah there would be
there would be sessions where because
the character would often get jettisoned
yeah smash into things so like hundreds
and hundreds of screaming's into smashes
and that can't air that's just like
[Laughter]
[Applause]